alors comme ça vous voulez changer le
monde
cette question je l'entend de plus en
plus autour de moi avec plus ou moins
d'ironie et pourtant quelle étrange
question vous voulez changer le monde
le monde ne va pas attendu pour changer
il me semble ce qui nous est donné c'est
d'interagir avec un monde qui change
discutez apprendre faire c'est ça a
finalement changé le monde
je pense que la question est
fondamentalement mal posé je pense qu'il
faut plutôt se demander comment on peut
changer le monde
comment on peut interagir avec un monde
qui change à la fin des années 60 une
période pleine d'émulation
intellectuelle
il y avait une publication qui faisait
un peu l'unanimité dans les communautés
hippies titre de san francisco il
s'agissait du world of catalogue
c'est un catalogue un peu bordélique qui
rassemble et des outils des techniques
pour sortir de la société industrielle
qui apparaissait alors comme violente
chaque nouveau numéro était en fait une
agrégation de l'ancien augmenté du
courrier des lecteurs
chacun pouvait comme ça en fonction de
ses compétences de ces expériences
participé à la rédaction du catalogue
le catalogue a influencé toute une
génération d'entrepreneurs
un des plus célèbres d'entre eux steve
jobs le mentionner souvent est mentionné
souvent cette image qui en fait la
quatrième de couverture du dernier
numéro du catalogue est mentionné
notamment cette maxime ce terrain
ghristi foolish dans la façon dont ça va
influencer sa vie le fondateur du
catalogue stewart brand est un
personnage un peu atypique qui a
papillonné entre les premières
communautés hippies les entrepreneurs de
menlo park à san francisco et les
laboratoires du mighty sa volonté et une
de ses volontés avec le catalogue
c'était de faire émerger une forme de
conscience collective une forme de
conscience partagée
la photo que vous voyez ici c'est une
des unes du world are catalogue mais
c'est surtout la première photo public
de la terre vue de l'espace
imaginez un peu l'impact que cela peut
avoir
lorsque des gens reçoivent une telle
photo entre leurs mains pour la première
fois parce que vous voyez des frontières
non un seul astre
ce que vous voyez des frondes des
options à la survie de l'humanité non la
terre est rien autour
quand on marche sur terre on a
l'impression d'être dans un
environnement a fini puisque l'horizon
se déplace avec nous avec ce type de
photos on prend conscience qu'on a un
pouvoir infinie dans un monde fini
c'est un basculement anthropologique
nous sommes tous sur le même bateau
puisque nous avons pu voir le bateau le
catalogue malgré un rythme un rythme de
parution un peu chaotique du fait d'un
financement plus qu'aléatoire arrive
tout de même à agréger comme ça tout un
tas de communauté et puis en 1985 alors
qu'internet est encore tout balbutiant
stewart brand va co fondé vie well be
well c'est la plus ancienne communauté
en ligne visuelle ce sont des forums sur
lesquels vous allez pouvoir discuter de
sujets divers et variés et les premières
communautés qui vont s'approprier cet
outil
ça va être les communautés hippies qui
est graviter autour du catalogue hywel
ça va être le berceau de d'initiatives
qui ont structuré l'internet tel qu'on
le connaît aujourd'hui avec notamment la
fondation de wired qui est le grand
magazine de la silicon valley la
fondation de la fff qui electronic
frontier foundation qui et défend les
droits des internautes ou encore la
création de craiglist sorte de leboncoin
à l'américaine l'internet qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui est fortement marqué par ce
mouvement sociologique des hippies du
offline ou online
regardez tous et toutes ces injonctions
à partager que vous avez sur vos réseaux
sociaux
regardez aujourd'hui l'explosion de la
consommation collaborative savez ces
usages plutôt que la possession et
comment on va mettre en relation une
offre et une demande entre particuliers
grâce à internet
c'est toutes ces startups blabla car
airbnb mais c'est aussi toute une
pléiade de projets qui vont mettre le
lien social la construction du lien
social au coeur de leur initiative
regardez également le retour de cette
idée de réappropriation de la technique
autour de tendance comme le do it
yourself l'open manufacturing
c'est ce sont ces communautés qui
s'agrège autour de ces lieux qu'on
appelle fablabs hacker space est con et
qu'on appelle makers toutes ces
tendances
elle participe au retour de cette utopie
d'une horizontale isation de la société
cette utopie elle est portée par des
imaginaires qui sont présents dans le
média internet
alors qu est ce qu un imaginaire un
imaginaire ça a plein de définition il y
en a une qui me semble assez éclairante
et que j'aime beaucoup c'est celle de
patrice flichy patrice flichy qui a
notamment écrit un livre qui s'appelle
l'imaginaire d'internet est dans ce
livre il définit l'imaginaire comme une
force qui fait que l'utopie technique
devient une idéologie politique et par
ce mouvement
on va faire fi d'une partie de la
réalité en fait on va cacher il a conclu
une partie de la complexité de la
réalité mais on va pouvoir mobiliser des
gens et des énergies autour d'une vision
imaginaire c'est un outil de
communication très puissant mais si vous
n'entrez pas dans une certaine réalité
ça reste un nouveau utopique au sein de
richert nous on parle d'utopistes
pragmatique
oui cher c'est une communauté
internationale qui essaye de promouvoir
l'émergence d'une société plus
collaborative notamment grâce au
numérique du ch ce sont des gens qui
vont porter des projets qui vont
développer de l' influence en servant de
ces imaginaires mais on espère ne pas
être dupe du fait qu'ils masquent une
partie de la réalité
oui cher c'est surtout l'histoire d'une
discussion qui a commencé autour d'un
hashtag sur twitter autour d'un blog
et puis très vite qui s'est passé dans
des cuisines dans sur des terrasses de
café et trois ans après finalement ce
qu'on fait avec we share c'est qu'on
continue à design et ses espaces qui
héberge ces discussions
alors ces espaces ces espaces peuvent
être en ligne
on a un magazine on a des forums mais
ils peuvent être aussi un fly dans la
vie réelle c'est des événements on en a
fait un peu partout en europe et en
amérique du sud
le plus gros événement qu'on organise le
plus gros espace de discussion il
s'appelle le windsurf est le we share
fest
ces trois jours de conférences ses mille
personnes à paris mille personnes qui
viennent de partout dans le monde et
qu'ils discutent de l'impact du
numérique sur l'émergence de cette
société plus collaborative si vous venez
au richard fest vous allez croiser plein
d'utopistes pragmatique mais si
finalement si on devait garder qu'une
seule chose de oui cher qu'une sonnac
qu'une seule action c'est de construire
une culture
parce que c'est cette culture qui va
garantir une cohérence entre ce qu'on
racontera berlin paris ou rio
et c'est cette culture qui va permettre
aux imaginaires de s'ancrer dans une
réalité cette culture on la définit par
six piliers alors ses piliers ont les
discute assez souvent ils sont pas
arrêtés aujourd'hui je vous présente
cela mais pourront bouger
il bouge tous les six mois je vous en
présente et 2000 people in my life donc
rencontrer les gens dans la vraie vie au
sein de richert on passe énormément de
temps derrière notre ordi on utilise
tout un tas d'outils que vous connaissez
peut-être et on s'est rendu compte assez
vite que si on passait pas du temps de
l'autre côté de l'ordi avec la personne
qui était de l'autre côté de l'ordi il
se passe rien en ligne une des autres
valeurs actions donc action au sein de
richert vous demandez pas la permission
vous faites vous écoutez les retours
qu'on vous fait vous y verrez sur ce que
vous avez fait et vous apprenez alors à
la question comment j'essaye de faire
pour changer le monde ou en tout cas
comment je fais pour interagir avec un
monde qui change
j'essaye d'identifier dans les
organisations que je fréquente que ce
soit des grands groupes des start up des
projets d'innovation sociale des
mouvements politiques
ce genre d'utopistes pragmatique ce
genre de personne qui est capable de
faire vibrer des imaginaires et de
mobiliser derrière une vision alors y'a
pas de profil type
vous en avez sûrement partout autour de
vous et si vous voulez aller vers
l'émergence de cette société 3.0 c'est
vers ce type d'entrepreneurs là qu'il
faut aller
quand je parle d'entrepreneurs je parle
pas forcément de la personne qui veut
diffuser son application à travers le
monde
je parle de celui qui est capable de
penser et faire en dehors du cadre que
l'histoire lui a donné quand ce cadre
l'ua paraît obsolète et c'est ça c'est à
ça que sert finalement l'utopie l'utopie
dans un moment de transition comme dans
celui qu'on vit ça permet d'offrir une
nouvelle représentation d'une époque et
internet c'est ça c'est un outil c'est
un environnement qui peut nous permettre
de penser et faire en dehors du cadre
c'est pour ça que je pense que le
numérique est l'outil des artisans de
cette société 3.0 et il faut mettre cet
outil au service de notre créativité
sociale et politique
merci